[Music]
was on camera that whole time yo yeah I
look to the side I thought we went
someplace else and I was just gonna
drink my water and look at my cup thank
God you didn't yeah thank God people
didn't see you being human exactly no
one must ever see my human side my need
for hydration here's how the survey
works we asked three celebrities to
complete a phrase our first phrase was I
feel like I'll never catch up with Tom
Hanks wrote the latest trends in
technology Zooey Deschanel wrote
watching my favorite TV shows Ronnie
from Jersey Shore wrote human evolution
popular in states where people Barack
Obama wrote are progressive thinkers
Mitt Romney wrote wants smaller
government Ron Paul wrote regularly hunt
skin and boil squirrel sometimes when I
look in the mirror I think we MHA see
wrote who is that old man Marissa Tomei
wrote my mother looking back at me
Steven Tyler wrote someone dropped raw
meat on a dream catcher
[Applause]
you're coming to hell with me pal he
didn't say it like was a bad no no it's
good there's nothing like slipping into
a Don Cheadle wrote warm bed Gwyneth
Paltrow wrote new summer dress tan mom
wrote pizza oven my neighbors call me
Derek Jeter wrote mr. Jeter Albert
Pujols wrote Albert Roger Clemens wrote
perjury Jones my favorite color is Mitt
Romney wrote blue John McCain wrote
green President Obama wrote I killed
Osama bin Laden
[Music]
I'm tired of being harassed by Brooklyn
Decker wrote creepy guys Kevin Spacey
wrote tabloid journalists Wilford
Brimley wrote coroner's damnit I'm
[Applause]
stupid
yes lie down as a kid I hated when my
mom made me Charlie dear oh go to bed
early Mindy Kaling wrote brush my teeth
Mel Gibson wrote give away my Hitler
trading cards they're collectibles oh
boy and finally I grew up during Jane
Lynch wrote the Vietnam War Harrison
Ford wrote the Korean War Larry King
wrote the war between the Apes with
sticks
[Applause]